[Musik]
die nächste dritte hält diesen kasten
black box
da drehen könnte war damit einmal wieder
könig posaune gott als schöne chance und
im interview 2 unleashed
das geht irgendwie noch ob der schuhe
die hätten wir so einen viertel fast
süchtig in der kampf werde
los geht's mehr einfluss haben
der einzige monat muss der bus nummer 49
bis haltestelle 4
fidesz-chef tourist unterwegs
klar ist dass rechnungen keine gute
woche
was ich da auch große hochwasser hoch
sie transportieren den tiefbau umstiegen
was ist also das buch the wire hat das
sind die drogenabhängigen oder häufig
mittagessen seehofer auf informationen
hoch ist kein schreiben kompetenz für
den mono jojoy sorge also zweitürer
laufen und ich denke die kühe oder aber
schon zum klientel wie gott monat mit
lutum womit er im poker um macht und wie
viel freude es dauert doch ein
kamerateam
zusammen mit suchtkranke das ist monats
mit drin
[Musik]
da mache ich gut sie hat sich ganz
normal verhalten
aber die weltweit im fernsehen werden
anonymisiert ich bin halt so mithelfen
kochen mit mir die ich ein besuch auf
der gasse und langjährige
drogenkonsument mittwoch
und für die neugier drucke probiert seit
der andy rihs gesperrt nach kicks
entzugsversuche sogar anderer zieht im
gefängnis ist an die immer abhängig zwar
nicht mehr frische methadonprogramm aber
nicht nur programm open hat der gasse
rookies konsumation drogen und ruf sicht
eine seite die mehr dem der software
das ist doch ein raucher oder geduldet
ob raucher konsumiert jaha sieg geholt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
jeden tag fleißig bis sonntag geht es in
der gasse hochsitz mittag
es zeichnet gratis es kostet 5 franken
warum warum so wenig fehler und sitzt
gott nötig gut das problem drogen oder
alkohol anteilig vor armut betroffen und
rund 100 future messe
es kann nicht jeder marine laufen
sondern man muss sich registrieren
wer nötig der region wohnt oder
minderjähriges konkret zugang über 450
liter gesamten hinter schweiz verkehren
war an dem stoff
er schied kopiere was er mit dieser
meint drogen rauchen und auf das freut
das nicht so ist
worum es geht
[Musik]
david ich gemacht
aber keine informationspflicht
als melua future warum wenn du für ihre
fehlen
warum sollte ich jetzt im moment doch
wie schwierig wie sie stets extrem oder
also abend die ich glaube höheren
inflation oder wie sie machen aber da
haben sie jetzt brauchen die aggressiv
stetig beruhigt sich wieder und wie
immer da so hoch erzählte an die
plötzlich recht persönlich
so verschieden die pflicht ruft daher
werden sie sind in jeder box beruhen
wird vor der drogenkonsument am meisten
genutzt es gibt aber auch an schnupfen
oder spritze und ja es verstört mir
recht wieder rund um mich bemüht hat die
droge konsumiert aber lieber als
irgendwo in der öffentlichkeit wie zu
platzspitz zeitpunkt für die süchtige
bedeutet tag schied die rahmen mehr
hygiene und weniger stress und freezers
gesellschaft dass man weniger in kontakt
mit dem ganzen mit im aber laufe sprich
mir einen erfordert wenig dass der oper
erlebte
die ein das sind sie ein bisschen sehr
witzig sind die anderen überhaupt nicht
wo das ist mein zug will ja aber ich
aber merke jetzt aber das merkt man
nicht dann machen wir das selber richtig
bemerkt
ihr seid schon kleine blut das ist ja du
bist kein junkie ein konsument zu zeigen
ich konnte mir ja wenn ich schon noch
ein bisschen was sind liegt wie du sind
ja selbst schuld dass sie drogen nahmen
die diebe mit dem schuhtick gemüse haben
so sorge mache obwohl sie seit wollte
ich sicher ob ich mir die multi channel
zu wachsen
[Musik]
das buch ist für iris baumann
sie sind jeden tag tor
jeder
[Musik]
es lebe bestimmt vor der droge schon
nach einem tag der halle noch ein
berühmtes folgen was ihm gesuchten ihr
ganzer stolz
eine selber nicht richtig ist
am haltegurt gaza hoch wie zur glut
verstreuen sich der stadt luzern und
umgebung
die allermeisten hände honig oder
irgendwo wenigstens bis zum anderen noch
gestern ist mein blick rift valley ein
anderer stoff denken über textilien und
wo nie vorher inneren borke druck macht
hätte stören jetzt vordruck zur kaiser
und was machst du am morgen
[Gelächter]
wir haben sind da an die ist der treff
warum laden
der erste termin vom tag sie sind am
morgen bei die show im dropbox der
kontrollierte trocken ab
[Musik]
und am ende immer am morgen wurde auch
sehr oft hier unter wenigsten und der
trend zieht sich für die gruppe da
spiele zwei institutionen zweimal die
psychiatrische dienst ersatzdrogen ab
wie zum beispiel methadon und der verein
kirchliche gassenarbeit bietet den ort
besucht tranken der doktorand am halb
weniger gas hub und atrium zum
konsumieren im hinterhof findet dass
lidl statt nur so viel bis zum
konsumieren 100 von der polizei und
streng überwacht von der user eigene
security der oberwelt konsumiere muss es
nun offiziell
denn etwa 25 minute zählt bermejo als
base kunden über ziert grund des tages
führt über es hat auch junge liter
weitere und manager von normalen job
band dear wenn verständlicher wie cnet
dass man sie viel mit die anonyme der
kamera hat sind die langjährige
konsumenten wieder
ich kann mit ihm in so genannte warum
man darf spritze
dies bildet die flag fachfrau sandra
zustande bringen
[Musik]
die affen programm das sich synthetisch
hergestelltes heroin
trotz der ersatzdroge rund dreimal am
tag und auch jährigen hus nahm die
allermeisten wo ihm kontrollierte drogen
programm sind auch viele kontakten dahl
aufstellen
okay das 20
das lag mir dauert war ich als kritisch
darüber nicht so haben mobile ein
überblick
seit die zeit noch nie bekommen
bingo
[Musik]
drogen
das ist vielleicht auch zum vergessen
gemacht hat meinte rettig und begleitet
und ist ein auftrag dass sie da wenn es
um
der dechant funktioniert das auf unser
auftrag der auftrag nicht primär
abstinenz sondern dass die sucht rang
kreisky plötzlich und für mehr als
gesellschaft rentierzucht nicht für die
zucht
der verein kirchliche gassenarbeit hilft
mit verschiedenen angeboten versuchen
ein seelsorger bietet handwerker
menschlicher halt braucht er
sozialberatung hilfe sucht ranken ihres
leben und speziell ihre finanzen wieder
in griff übertrug und dann geht's los
paradies kessler seymour xi dem hus
wertet familien unterstützt wo versucht
oder armut betroffen sind
zwischen ort wohin spiele konto schüler
aufgabe hilfe bekommt und alle zeichens
mittagessen ins paradies geistlich für
viele familien ein sicherer hafen in
stürmischen zeiten
aldi angebot fotografen haben werden zur
hälfte durch die öffentliche hand
finanziert und zum anderen mit spenden
und fairere geldern suchen die gassen
abend wieder wo frisch um abstürze sind
oder sich selber keine hilfe suchen
sozialarbeiterinnen natalie groh und mal
ist natürlich
der platz vorm bahnhof luzern ist ein
von der wenigen ort wonach linie szene
zeigt und da darf man von eurem profil
xenia unnötige gast auch zum beispiel
zwei ganz junge frauen bei die süchtig
beide obdachlos und mehr erfahren
tragisches ein klient wobei die grenze
und herzig bestehen sowie das sozial gut
verständlich verstimmt passiert dann
aber fiel
sie hatte
überdies sollen verschiedene gründe
jetzt was ich noch kraft von der dauer
nicht zum ersten mal auf die junge
frauen auswahl ist mit einer bleibe
dürften ja mein job das ist ja auch um
jene betriebe für die öffnung hier
ich habe mit jenen sowie sind
registriert sie haben mir schon wichtig
nation masche freiheit darstellt noch
schwierig aber davon 20 frauen sich
prostituieren oder stellen gestrichen
ja das ist natürlich so dass es nicht
drauf stehe ich ganz oben verstopfen
soll sie natürlich bei jedem team mit
dem sie unter tel
oder aber man sagte mir geschlossen
[Musik]
richtige methode immer erster stelle vor
der freunde der familie fordert hin und
schlussendlich sogar vom eigenen leben
[Musik]
der nächste marke ist ein tag wie sind
nur mit drei mal im jahr geht luzerner
gasse tätig konnte sie hat der stolze
flakon elftes exemplar der anbieter
stellt sich weg zum sieg auf der alm dem
stress nicht dass der neubau durch sehr
stark auf platz zwei
aber es braucht ja nur etwas für die ja
quatsch wenn die gasse zu kaufen
sehr viel weniger lustig zweite große
stars kati witt wo richtig sehen wo
genau dieses leben ist schlimm
[Gelächter]
der andi hat prothetik ein franke zahlt
und verkauft sich für zwei frauen
kredite vom engel und danach werden wir
jetzt die nächsten schuss kann ich deine
küsse dem die ezb habe
daher dann die recht für uster für jede
mit integrierter geld machen was er will
auch wenn das sprichwort nach verpulvert
der andi worauf die restlichen exemplare
tätig und ich kann zurück ganze woche
wieder kontakt und anlaufstelle verteilt
sandra mura kleider alles spenden
all das gehört so wirklich vom mensch
versucht hat auch dusche und ein mal pro
monat gibt es mit gab jeden tag aber
plötzlich wird hektisch in opfern dass
wir schwierige situationen will offenbar
sprechen
andererseits nicht notambulanz ohne
die zahlen recht angespannt im schweißen
dann bleibt ein schwieriger fall
ja sogar den opfern situation so wie es
nicht so oft vorkommt aber wenn es da
stand wo wahrscheinlich relativ viel
medikament geschlossenheit der heime und
den notar nach
denn ich war schon nicht witzig und
setzten eine so gute stunden in der
woche
plutos masse rohstoff halbmast der
zustand von asse zu meinem wesen
abschätzen wenn man etwas bessere dass
er sich nicht verantworten abgabe
schließlich entscheidet sich sandra zum
d'ambulanz ohne
[Musik]
kurze zeit später unter junge zum glück
wieder zu bewusstsein
letzte runde in der gasse suchen es
setze mit der stammgäste im hof mit dem
abend unter motor etwas anders
münchen
eine prostituierte statt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
warum ich denn noch laufen die abnötigen
untergang sondern nur der ausgang von
der gasse hoch wozu gemacht im oberen
stock wird aufgehoben
sandra entschluss für andré vom schicht
er stahl geld für die stoff für dienen
es geht zum frage wo sie ahnen
vielleicht möchte ich gar nicht so genau
wissen
sucht macht mir viel robic sandra und
ihre kolleginnen heile aber ein ort wo
menschen u font font a sind und wohin
geht was jeder pups braucht
menschlichkeit würde und das stück
geborgenheit
[Musik]